[Music]
you're listening to anxiety with Michael
Rosenbaum how are you folks uh great
episode today it's really exciting um I
you know I've been friends with James
Gunn for a long long time whether he
likes to admit that or not
um he always gives me [__] but Jimmy I
know you love me that's all I could say
and uh a lot going on you know he just
went to Ireland
to uh I don't want to use the word dump
but Spread spread hit the his father his
father's ashes who I adored who anyone
who ever came into contact with big Jim
Gunn loved him and I miss him and I
think that was the whole family was
going out there and it was very personal
James is always you know worn his
emotions on his sleeves and he's uh it's
you know what you see is what you get
sometimes he'll say stuff because you
know that you know he's not gonna
[__] you and um I'm just uh super
proud of him
uh I was friends with him we were doing
things like PG porn and he asked me to
do PG porn and I did some interview show
with you know that he wanted to do and
um
just going to you know his screening for
uh slitherer and you know he was always
so passionate about everything he did
and he just put it all out there like
you could see it you could see the dirt
you can see the grime you could see the
work and
um
so I'm just it's amazing it doesn't
Shock Me
but it shocks me to think that one of
your buddies who you know you're roaming
around the town with and doing your
thing and making what you're making
then all of a sudden you're doing
blockbuster movies that you're directing
and then you're running a studio
it's asinine to think then you know
someone coming from such humble Origins
uh you know it's just it's a cool thing
I I think uh
dreams do come true I think this is what
he's always wanted was to make movies to
tell stories since he was a kid making
you know eight millimeter eight
millimeter 16 millimeter movies with his
with his brothers and his sister Beth I
Can't Forget You
but uh I find it fascinating and
exciting and then watching him get
married and going to Aspen and going to
his bachelor party and you know no
strippers or anything it's just a bunch
of guys hanging out of the house telling
stories
and it was emotional and uh we talk
about a bit about everything
um obviously
you know me I'm still like the kid candy
store like hey what about the you know
we can only talk about so much and I can
get so so deep but he's pretty damn open
and I appreciate that Jimmy and uh you
deserve all the success in the world and
it's awesome uh
please follow the show please uh if you
if you like this episode you're like hey
it wasn't a bad interview maybe you'll
listen to it and the handles Ryan inside
of you pod on Twitter inside of a
podcast on Instagram and Facebook that
is correct the store is the inside of
you online store we've got a bunch of
new stuff on there the talk fill podcast
is going we just finished season two so
make sure you watch that and um
what else I will be in
uh I'll be in DC I'll be in Rhode Island
I'll be in uh a lot of cons coming up so
check it out and the 24th of June
um sunspin my band will be playing
sunspin.com get tickets there's tons of
cool merch there too and you can go to
stageit.com and type in Sun spin and uh
support the uh support the band support
the band and without further Ado why
don't we just do this huh let me just do
this let's get inside of James Gunn it's
my point of view you're listening to
inside of you with Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience what were you just eating
what was it a lozenge yeah a cough drop
is it because I don't want to cough
during the this interview that's good is
it a Los Angeles
when I was a kid I always thought it was
a lozenger
nobody thinks that that's yeah I know
I'm not you know I I didn't get good
grades yeah are you aware of that
yeah I could guess that I could trace it
back to from my knowledge of you today
do you remember some of my stories at
your um bachelor party yeah you made
everybody cry one time I I couldn't
believe that I I said yes I go I'm sorry
for sharing that you go no actually you
really made me emotional yeah that's the
first time I ever liked you is that true
I mean you like me maybe more after that
right I did like you more after that
really yeah no you really shared you
shared something incredibly uh personal
about yourself and everybody everybody
was crying
I didn't notice that even Chuck rovin
was getting Terry Chuck rovin The Big
Show Chuck was like wow he's [__]
this is heavy well we all got a little
heavy I thought that was what was nice
about it it wasn't like your typical
Hollywood bachelor party where everybody
goes the strip bars and girls it was
just the guys your friends yeah at a
cool place yeah at a house doing little
things for you and eating well and
telling stories yeah and that's what you
wanted yeah that's what I wanted that's
what I like because you've been to the
other ones
I have been but I haven't been to it I
don't think I've been to a like a well
let's see now I've been to strip club
Bachelor parties but it's been a long
time yeah me too it's been a long time
and last time I went to one I went to
one I won't say who the person is I went
to one in uh Vegas and then a lot of the
guys went to a strip club but I didn't
go to the strip club why didn't you
because I'm in a relationship now and
you're like don't want to even go there
don't even want to see you don't want to
like just you put yourself in any
situation well it's it's it's not that
you don't trust yourself it's not even
that I wouldn't go it's just I just
don't have the desire to go also uh you
know
I get recognized everywhere now so it's
like I don't really want to go to a
strip club and have pictures show up
somewhere or whatever it's like that's
true you have to worry about that now
yeah oh head of DC strip bar well this
was long before this was long before
that yeah that was a long time ago but
even still I wouldn't get like Lap Dance
I mean for me in my relationship I would
consider lap dances probably not Kosher
within my relationship really yeah so if
I was in a relationship with a woman and
I went to a strip bar and I had a lap
dance I guess you get around I don't
make I don't I don't make rules for
other people that's you that's for me
right yeah yeah that's for me that's
good yeah you know I was thinking about
this and
God damn it well we're going to use it
don't worry you won't be able to hear it
it's your favorite it's Toto
oh my God you know my music you know
what's funny is you you lambast me for
my music yet
sometimes in your soundtracks there's
songs that I'm like
That's A Rosenbaum yeah I use some
Rosenbaum songs yeah I know but you have
to realize my my soundtracks are
tailored to fit the movie they aren't
necessarily what my tastes are you know
that my tastes I know you're very
different you know I mean Guardian
Street's a little bit different there's
a couple songs that are very much James
Gunn songs in there there's you know the
song by X poor girl that's one of my
favorite songs right there's the
replacement song I will dare that's a I
mean classic James Gunn song what would
you say is a Rosenbaum song in that
movie in that one that you go ah Rose
mama like this and you know less than
that one but maybe I don't know you like
heart you like crazy yeah come on yeah
yeah yeah did you hear the rendition of
uh the Led Zeppelin I did actually isn't
that great yeah just you're not a huge
heart fan no I like heart you like heart
Zeppelin fan are you really not no I
like them I have a problem with the fact
that they ripped off a lot of those
early songs like which songs they're
first albums they have they had to share
all the credit with old guys that they
ripped off they now have to share credit
for big songs all their big songs bro
they they re they just grip them all off
I never knew this yeah a lot of people
don't know it they just stole songs from
like black dog they sold I can't
remember but Stairway to Heaven what
song was that that was another song like
an old uh you know Blues musician or
something they I swear look at the
credits they had to change them all so
it was and they weren't like that when
they first you know released the album
was it so when you first heard their
albums you're like this is amazing and
then when you found that out it kind of
well no listen I'm a punk rock kid right
so I liked you know I was a you know I
was I was too young for British punk
rock but I remember I was very young
when I saw the Sex Pistols on uh the
American Music Awards for the first time
that must have been ten right and I saw
the sex pistols and I it I couldn't
believe what I was seeing I mean first
of all I can't believe that that was on
you know it's like Dick Clark announcing
the American Music Awards yeah and now
live from London the sex pistols and
then they have the sex films and people
with enormous safety pins through their
chins and you know God saved the queen
and he says and I just I couldn't
believe it I mean I'm here a kid in
rural Manchester Missouri like something
I I never thought I'd seen it I became
obsessed with that and so you know over
the next few years I just always there
was always this thing that like the Sex
Pistols were the most extreme like they
were the coolest dri uh dead Kennedy's
uh well that was more so I was mostly
into British Punk so it was like you
know the Sex Pistols The Clash the jam
Buzzcocks Generation X
um you know did you like the Smiths or
anything or was that too melodic I like
the Smiths but you have to remember the
Smiths was a little bit later so this I
got into Punk well I guess I got into
Smithson in high school right after I
got into but I was never like huge Smith
I like the Smiths where there's some
songs in Guardians that you really
wanted in there but you're like you know
they fought you on it all no nobody ever
fought me on anything really first one
first one they probably did no no never
felt me on anything they what happened
was so uh you know on the first script
you know because I write all the songs
into the script right and on the first
script you know Kevin feige read the
script and he said
um oh you know he says he said this in
interview so I'm not like betraying any
confidence he goes oh well that's that's
cute he thinks these are the songs that
are gonna be in the movie
because that's a No-No that's a a sort
of one of those I mean there's a lot of
no-no's in script writing that are not
necessarily no-nos if you're also the
director because to me the script is a
blueprint from the movie so I put lots
of things in like I put in uh Guardians
3 script I have drawings of all the
characters that I put in the script so
you know there's drawings of Flora and
Lila and all those things that I drew
and put in the script that would
necessarily be a No-No if you just
because you wanted the reader to when
the studio read this you wanted them to
see see what you're talking about not
just say oh yeah I wanted you to know
what kind of what they looked like an
emotion would come out and I wanted to
set a you know a design for them and
also you know there were little things
like you know at the end when nowhere
and
um
um the orete line up in a certain way
when craglin and nebula are driving them
towards each other I I drew a diagram of
what that looked like because it's kind
of a complex thing to you know write out
but visual it's it's pretty easy to see
are you a good artist or do you get help
sometimes on the drawings I'm not a I'm
not a I'm a I'm an okay cartoonist right
so I can you know draw okay you know
enough to you know put in like uh you
know what floor looks like or you might
would you ever ask for help I want you
to can you draw something a little
better so they can get a visual of it
you have those guys right gals you know
I mean I I did have you know we did some
of that but you know but at the
beginning it was just me drawing it you
know one thing knowing you is like
I mean when you were a kid is there
something you always wanted to be
for lack of a better word in control of
your own destiny and control of your
like your Visions this is the way I want
to do it I've always have you always
been like that I want it done this way
and this is how we're going to do it
success or failure this is my vision and
did you sway away did you Veer away from
that ever or did you kind of because a
lot of people be like okay the studio
wants us I'm gonna give them what I
think they want and what I want
no I don't I don't I it's it's more
complicated than either of those things
for me because I think the thing that
you say that doesn't strike true is you
know success or failure either way it
at the end of the day once you finish a
project it is success or failure it's
either way it's whatever it is like once
I finish something it's out of my hands
that's going to be whatever it is it's
gonna make however much money it's going
to be it's going to be received by the
audience and critics however it's going
to be received but I want something to
be successful so when you're making a
film and when you're making a movie for
hundreds of millions of dollars I don't
sit there and go oh this is all about my
expression and it's going to be whatever
I want it to be no matter what right
however so I listen to other people a
lot like when you're on my on my set
I'm constantly asking people questions
I'm constantly you know saying what do
you what do you think of that you know I
love that my VFX supervisor you know
Steph sits next to me and I'm constantly
saying do you think you like that or was
it better when he did it the other way
you know
um do you think that shot works is that
little hitch in the shot is that gonna
screw us up can you fix it you probably
know in your gut but you want someone
you respect and Trust to kind of confirm
that maybe
I just want to know what other people's
opinions are so I like taking that into
account that's a part of the filmmaking
process for me other people's opinions
um you know the testing process for me
is is is
you know partially harrowing and
partially really fun if you use the
testing process in the right way where
you show a movie in front of an audience
and you find out what works and what
doesn't work it can be really helpful to
you now it's awful because you're
putting a movie out there and when
you're showing it in Los Angeles people
are especially critical
also when your movies test really well
it feels really great also I have to say
right so I've been really fortunate with
the past few
um
but uh but it does help you know seeing
what works and what doesn't what
confuses people what doesn't you know
when you're making a movie you're making
a giant machine that's supposed to make
people and audiences feel a certain way
right and so you want to find out what
works because sometimes something will
stop people that you didn't intend and
sometimes something will confuse people
that you didn't know about you know that
you always are revealed something in
those early test screenings
inside of you is brought to you by neuro
hacker qualia cenolytic let me tell you
something about this
um I take this every day I've talked
about this before Ryan but I I didn't
even know I was taking uh something from
a sponsor I thought I had purchased it
myself I didn't know they delivered me
and I started just taking it because oh
this is this gotta be and I noticed a
difference and then all of a sudden I go
oh you have to read sponsors uh ads and
I was like well that's good because I
like this product a lot
um it's pretty fantastic because look if
you're the older you get and you look
you got to start out it's good to just
try and be healthy your whole life but
especially I'm 50 now
and uh you know staying in uh physically
fit
you know and mentally fit place is just
as important your physical and your
mental are all they all go together and
um you know and then using this product
and knowing that I'm valuing the most
research-backed ingredients known to
science for a better aging process it
just it makes me feel better it makes me
feel better and every morning I take it
um our sponsor neuro hacker packs seven
of the most science backed synolytic
ingredients into one formula called
qualia cenolytic and you can take it
just two days a month to help you
achieve fast noticeable benefits for a
much better aging process we're always
trying to slow down the aging process I
look in the mirror and I'm like good
Lord what happened to you but I've been
taking this and I've known a substantial
noticed a substantial difference I I
really have it's just something that I
don't know what it is but I just seem
more focused I feel like um when I'm
coming up with ideas more from me it's
just helping me and I'm so glad that I
started taking it before I knew they
were a sponsor so I I strongly suggest
um my body my energy levels feel younger
definitely younger uh after just a
couple of months of of taking this stuff
so it's easy uh just two days a month I
noticed massive aging benefits making an
easy addition to my health regimen
the formula is non-GMO vegan gluten-free
and the ingredients are meant to
complement one another factoring in the
combined effect of all ingredients
together and Ryan guess what else
this stuff is backed it's backed by a
hundred day money back guarantee so you
have almost three months to try
qualiosynolytic from neuro hacker at no
Financial Risk and decide for yourself I
want you to do that do it for free
just try this stuff for three months
and tell me you don't feel more focused
tell me you don't feel different uh I
certainly do or I wouldn't be sitting
here we turned down a lot of sponsors
it's very hard but sometimes I'm like
well I don't believe in this product I
believe in neuro hacker so if you're in
your late 20s or older adding neuro
hackers qualius analytic to your diet
can play a crucial role in combating
negative aging symptoms just go to
neurohacker.com inside for up to 50 off
qualius analytic and as a listener of
inside of you use the code inside at
checkout for an extra 15 off your first
purchase that's neuralhacker.com inside
to try qualius analytic with code inside
and start aging on your terms that's
neurohacker.com inside the tri-qualia
cenolytic with code inside and start
aging on your terms these statements
have not been evaluated by the Food and
Drug Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat care or prevent any disease inside
of you is brought to you by rocket money
you want to save money just listen this
is so easy rocket money how many times
you have subscriptions and you're like
why have I been paying for this it
happens to me all the time where you
want to see one of those shows on this
new streamer because there's a million
you're like it's on the streamer called
lumpy and lumpy has this show I want to
see so I have to subscribe and pay 7.99
and then I forgot it because it's a free
trial and now I've spent 89 on this show
you don't have to do that anymore
because rocket money is going to save
you money what's great about this is
rocket money cancel the subscription for
me that was otherwise
time consuming tricky I just forgot it
this is what they do I know the rocket
money has saved me hundreds of dollars
there's no doubt about that and I I
could save you up to much more than that
and it's worth it rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending helps you lower
your bills all in one place over 80
percent of people have subscriptions
that they forgot about and chances are
you're one of them yeah I'm one of them
and you know like the stars app just to
watch one show Ryan or that how about
the free gaming trial you never actually
used
rocket money will quickly and easily
find your subscriptions for you and for
any of you who don't want to pay for any
more just hit cancel and Rocket money
will cancel it for you it is that easy
rocket money also helps you manage all
your finances in one place and
automatically categorizes your expenses
so you can easily track your budget in
real time and also get alerted if
anything looks off over 3 million people
have used rocket money saving the
average person up to seven hundred and
twenty dollars a year what are you
waiting for this is easy rocket money
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com slash inside that's
rocketmoney.com inside
rocketmoney.com slash inside
now there's also this whole top two
boxes thing where I don't know if you
know have you've done testing right yeah
so you know that and there's you know no
STDs for audiences it's like in the top
two box is there's you know it's you
want uh the movie to test in the top two
boxes so you want very good in
excellence
um and sometimes you know usually you
know I've been fortunate because my
movies have tested well in the top two
boxes for the most part right
um uh but that can also be kind of uh
a harness trying to get those top two
boxes because what you want to know from
a test screening is what works what
doesn't you know what gets laughs what
moves people what confuses people you
know where do people go off course and
that really doesn't have anything to do
with top two boxes that has to do with
more than anything else sitting in the
audience with them watching the movie
and kind of feeling it and then asking
questions of a focus group afterwards
right that's what helps the most
um but you know it's it's a it's a
process that can really work and some
directors have a big issue with it but I
don't you know we are but also the other
thing is I do a lot of what I would call
really small test groups so I have I
didn't invite you this time because
you're in the movie right but I have a
small group of people you know I showed
a lot of groups the movie of people I
really trust and you learned a lot from
that yeah filmmakers directors actors
writers do they sit in a room sort of in
and answer say questions or do you like
like it blindly like they write it down
so they don't they don't write anything
down no I I ask them questions so will I
mean they can send me stuff afterwards
but but you don't get insulted at all
um I wouldn't say never get insulted but
yeah I'm pretty open you know because
I'm just I realize everybody's reaction
to a movie is just a reaction to a movie
so they made like a character they may
not like a character whatever but I'll
sit there we'll do all these mini test
screenings with like 20 20 to 30 people
and we'll show them you know certain
people have always been a part of this
group like right Jeremy Slater I show it
to every time my brother Brian my cousin
Mark Dave uh yarvo I show every time uh
Stevie yeah
Stevie not Stevie's acted almost on my
movie so I usually haven't shown him
earlier he's got a big part in this one
yeah like I noticed pretty big problem
yeah yeah real quick Stevie nobody knows
him but I do and I love him he's been a
lot of you see him you'll know him but
you do this it's for me
just do it for me like saying James I
guess I don't know whatever you talk
about
does he hate it he hates it he says that
that doesn't sound like me at all
um you know you I there's so many
questions I want to ask you he plays uh
he plays steam Stevie Blackheart plays
steamy blue liver he's a guy that sets
out all the uh cannons at the very end
you see more like in the ship and all
these things and like you know yeah
um
here's what I don't understand like you
always what don't you understand well
you've always wanted to make movies
right that's we know that well I mean
for the most part since you started
making movies you wanted to continue
making movies now what's hard for me to
wrap my head around is it's such a
daunting task to make a movie let alone
a successful movie
but then you're getting you're doing all
these things Guardians one is a huge
success Guardians 2 is a huge success
Suicide Squad Peacemaker all these
things and then someone's over at DC
says hey we want you to run the studio
yeah what would make someone first of
all did you think about saying no that's
not what I want to do and almost say no
when it first came up I was like
and it didn't come up nobody came to me
and said do you want to run DC but it
came to me very early in the process
would that be something you would be
interested in this is very early and I
was like nah I don't think so and the
the reasons were because it was me and
it wasn't me and Peter
um what made it appealing to me
eventually was because I also went to
Peter early on and he was like the same
way but what eventually became appealing
to me was doing it with Peter so Peter
Safran has been
he's been my manager since I first moved
to LA when he was back when he was the
president of Bilstein Gray
we're very close friends we've traveled
together we hang out with our families
together we're you know uh close friends
and we've gotten maybe one or two
arguments over the past 25 years
um of working together
we work together exceptionally well we
never step on each other's toes I
respect his opinion completely about
many things and he you know he respects
my opinion about creative stuff
and so when it came to us as us as a
pair and basically Peter sort of
managing everything working as a
producer and me basically working as a
director directing the creative aspects
of things that became a different story
that became suddenly an opportunity to
do something that had never been done
before to create the biggest Story Ever
Told across you know film television
gaming and more
um and to to Really create a cohesive
you know DC Universe
um I also knew that there was going to
be many challenges as we embarked on
that Journey because
um people have different ideas about how
things are supposed to be people have
all sorts of things that they love
whether they love things from you know
um you know the dceu or they love things
from the arrowverse they love things
from the animated worlds or whatever
that is something that we knew was going
to be a ring of fire we were gonna have
to walk through and you knew you were
going to be
loved and hated at the same time
um because there's always people out
there I knew
I've been used to being loved and hated
for a long time like you know this is
I'm on Twitter you know
um that's what Twitter is it's love and
hate you know Twitter is like the the
prisoner with the Love on one hand and
hate on the other I just they're just
punching you in the face with both sides
yeah uh
but uh I knew that it was I was knew
there was gonna be a period of hardship
you know and I knew that there had been
a spectacular uh missteps in the past
with all sorts of different choices good
answer uh but I'm thinking you know were
you thinking it to be the head of DC was
this going to hinder me from continuing
my filmmaking and being so you know
having all that passion into one Focus
as opposed to now I'm gonna direct a
movie but I also have to worry about
running a studio how do we do that yeah
I mean I think it kind of helps that out
because he's Peter helps it out I think
that it's always been you know I only
have so much time in my day I only have
so much I can do and I think it was
always a question about how much am I
going to spend on writing how much am I
going to spend on directing how much am
I going to spend you know ushering other
writers how much am I going to spend
ushering other directors
how much am I going to spend mapping out
you know sort of a story that other
writers can follow there's like I I only
have so much I can do I'm aware of that
um and uh and so yeah it did and I love
directing so it's I didn't want to lose
that either
um but in my heart I'm a Storyteller in
my heart I am I am not the same as other
filmmakers I don't think some other
filmmakers for sure but in my heart I
consider myself a Storyteller I don't
consider myself a director over being a
Storyteller I'm a Storyteller first and
that means whatever way I'm able to tell
that story I'm okay I have this
conversation with Dave yarva the
director of brightburn is one of my best
because he wants to direct movies like
he's mostly interested in directing
movies that's what he wants to do I'm
like I I you know if I can tell a great
TV story that is like doing Peacemaker
was absolutely great for me you know
doing a movie is absolutely great like
if I'm proud of what I'm putting out I'm
really happy it doesn't really matter to
me what that story is you know I started
out I wanted to write comic books when I
was younger if I was writing comic books
today I'd probably be I'd probably be
unhappy because you know so few people
are writing or reading comic books
um but I would probably be uh you know
really you know happy with what my job
was I'd enjoy that storytelling process
so that's what's important to me you
know I just happen to be good at
directing because directing takes a lot
of different weird talents that I do
many of those things but not all well
and you know being any director there's
always things that you do great and
things you do okay and uh and it's a
complicated job it's a very complicated
this episode is brought to you by better
help better help online therapy I talk
about therapy all the time and mental
health and this is what the podcast is
all about and I can't say enough about
Better Health they've been a great
sponsor and I think it's because it
helps people and it's simple and
affordable and uh you know I know how
much therapy can cost Ryan you've seen
like you know these guys in California
or everywhere it's just like they charge
a fortune per hour and it actually is
added stress so you're going into
therapy stress but better help to me is
is just the way to go
um if you're
worried about you know this the stigma
is it's going away people now I mean if
you if people train to get their muscles
your brain needs uh working out it needs
therapy you need therapy we need therapy
and you can talk about anything you'd be
surprised with little things that you
don't think are big and you talk to them
about a therapist and you're like oh
that's why I do that
oh you find so much rewarding things
about yourself that um you can turn
around you can change you could work on
and you have somebody here there who's a
trained professional and with everything
that's going on around us it can be hard
to focus on our well-being and many are
stretched thin and burned out from the
the candle burning you know both both
ends and that's that's me and you forget
about you
um therapy is is important you need
caring compassionate uh people who want
to take care of you and those are found
at betterhelp.com this totally online
source for therapy has helped thousands
find peace of mind and Direction during
these trying times betterhelp.com
understands we all need to develop
better coping skills and ways to set
boundaries to empower us to become the
best version of ourselves let me
recommend betterhelp.com if you're
considering trying therapy it's a quick
questionnaire
and you'll be matched with a licensed
therapist and guess what you can cancel
at any time you can quit a therapist and
say that's not working he or she is not
working or they they're not it's not
working and and go to someone else find
someone else that's that's it's a
process sometimes you get lucky boom
first one
um Ryan changed one time I did and now
it's great it's great I've been with
this one for over the year but there you
go from the horse's mouth no offense uh
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash inside this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection I think it's amazing
how
I look at your career and I was there
when you were like you know we were
hanging and you know doing you were
doing human Zee and people yeah I met
you when I was directing I met you when
I was directing my first movie
Slither yeah Slither yeah well I didn't
meet you then I met you before then we
met at the premiere for yeah and
everything and that's why we have mutual
friends and then we hit it off
um so I saw you doing these little
independent like these little labor of
loves like I'm gonna do this with my
brother or my friends and I'm gonna do
PG porn with the guys and I'm gonna do
this and you know and you were doing
stuff and you're working and you were
successful and you had a little money
you weren't like whoa yeah but and
you're still living in the house over in
Sherman Oaks and missed that house was
great yeah Studio City Studio City all
right yeah um should I get the address
no no no no no no no no no no no
somebody lives there I know I never do
are they like James Gunn lives here he
he had sex in this room
um but I look at that and I'm like did
you really think because I'm sure a lot
of people were like going hey he's a
good director he makes some cool [__] he
makes a cool horror movie makes this to
for a studio to give you a movie like
Guardians of the Galaxy
to say here
is
it just doesn't it seems unheard of that
they would be well it was his last movie
oh it was Memento okay let's give him go
or it was something huge something
whatever and it wasn't like you did
something that was a [__] home run
right it was good it was great but it
wasn't
so had it so I know the story but how
hard did you have to push to really get
something like that to prove yourself to
prove your vision that is gonna work I
would say I pushed really hard but also
I didn't push hard at all so it was a
combination you know because I was ready
to quit directing you know really 100 I
was like listen I was seeing how the
tide was turning I was seeing that you
know they were stopping making you know
mid-budget films
um and that I always liked creating
things that were somewhat within the
zeitgeist
and I was seeing that most of the movies
that they were going to let me direct
the 30 million dollar movies were gone
and that everything was big Marvel
movies and they're never gonna give me
that and yes I would love to do a Hulk
movie that was like big one at the time
uh you didn't think it was gonna happen
but I didn't think there was any way it
was going to happen even though I met
with Marvel a couple times about little
things I tried to get them to do hit
monkey I tried to get them to do
something else I didn't think that they
were going to hire them they were going
to hire me for some big movie you know
so I was like I don't think it's gonna
happen
I'm going to focus I see the future of
Television being really bright which I
was right about
um and I loved I just made a video game
that did very well and so I like doing
that so lollipop lollipop I was the head
of Nick I had no penis I love that
people still come up to me for
autographs so so it's like I had so I'm
like I'm gonna focus on television and
gaming that's what I'm gonna do I'm done
and I told my agent quit putting me out
for movies because I'm gonna focus on
television and gaming I just tried to
get some movie
um that they I couldn't get you know
which it seemed perfect for
um and then Marvel called up and said
will he come in we want to tell him
about this thing we're doing
and I was like God damn it you know
because Marvel's far away so at the time
not far now it's now it's in Burbank but
at the time it was in Manhattan Beach oh
that's an hour dude yeah and this is
like I was gonna have to drive home in
rush hour so I got to drive from Studio
City into Manhattan Beach so they could
pitch me and they could check me off
their list and they're not gonna it's
not really something that I'm Gonna
Wanna Do you think you're wasting three
or four hours I think I'm wasting four
hours of my day yeah right but I'm like
okay I drive down there I remember
stopping and getting a bite to eat
because I was early and talking to my
agent and or my lawyer Andrew hurwitz on
the phone
and being like yeah I mean I'm gonna go
on this thing is silly but
um when I go in there and then they
pitch me Guardians and
um and and that's really how it started
so it started like that and then you
know I've told the story many times
about how yeah yeah and came to me in
all this but I what I did was I worked
really hard like there's that speech
that um that Peter Quill gives in the
first Guardians of the Galaxy where he
says you know this is about giving a
[__] and that's what it was like for me
for the first time because I had
attributed All of My Success to really
hard work and not giving a [__] and I
allowed myself to give a [__] I allowed
myself to actually want to get this gig
and I sort of fell in love with the
concept of doing the Guardians of the
Galaxy I fell in love with I had always
wanted to do a Space Opera that was my
biggest dream to do a Space Opera in my
own way and I saw the opportunity here
and so I really worked hard and I
probably worked harder than anybody else
in terms of I wrote up this huge Bible
on what the visuals were going to be I
remember how I wrote a big I did
storyboarded the whole first sequence
from the movie
um and you know did a lot of work on the
characters that you know all this art
all these things it was harder to prep
this and get this so by the time you
went on set it was almost like probably
a little bit of a relief oh well yes on
this on the first Guardians absolutely
because you're prepared I was I mean
create I'm incredibly prepared but also
I wasn't what I wasn't prepared for was
on the other movies I had done
I was
better at most of the department heads
than at their jobs than they were you
know I knew more about a lot of those
jobs than they did because I couldn't
hire the best and the brightest right
now there's obviously
um some great people I work with but
this was on a different level but
suddenly I'm making a movie for over 100
million dollars and I've got you know
just the greatest
um you know department heads and my A.D
was better than I was my you know uh my
camera operator has he been in the ad on
all three
no no no Lars is no Lars started on two
on two I love Lars who is now a DC
employee Lars who is now you know you
know running a lot of our production if
you love him he was my age that was the
thing that I when I walked on set the
crew they were so amazing and your DP
sorry for memory lapse uh Henry Henry
Henry Bram who shot [__] he shot uh
you know Guardians uh three Suicide
Squad Guardians two he shot the flash
which people are gonna see is just one
of the greatest movies ever made so it's
like he's he's an incredible and such a
wonderful he you know they're just the
way he's like hey Michael how you been
man yeah he's so laid back he's not he
freaks out sometimes yeah Henry's not
laid back well he's gonna freak out you
have a big person say he freaked out I
just said he's not laid back all right
all right he's a little anxious he can
seem laid back but that's you know I
don't see those things because I'm not
an intense guy right uh you know I
normally don't write questions down but
I did because I didn't want to forget
him but I have side Squad and Peacemaker
are stories about very flawed people
when you say yeah I think they're all
all my stories are how do you handle
stories about Superman or Wonder Woman
Who are not flawed and are basically
Gods well I'm not writing Wonder Woman I
am writing Superman I know
um
but I think that's you know does
Superman's flawed I mean not all
characters have flaws there's not it's
not as if he's not flawed
um but he's also probably not he's not
flawed in the same way
Peter Quill is Peter Quill's a mess
right right he's not Peter Quill isn't
flawed in the same way Rocket Raccoon is
flawed rocking raccoon's a real mess you
know what I mean yeah so it's like these
are really deeply injured characters and
Superman is different than that but I
think that it's it's it's very
indicative of my own Journey that I've
been on you know personally
um through my life I think that I was a
lot more flawed when I started writing
Guardians than I am when I started
writing Superman
um I'm a lot less anxious I'm a lot less
I don't have the same problem which is
amazing to me how are you less anxious
now with all that's on your plate I was
having this conversation with Chris
McDonald our mutual good friend
and I said I don't know how he does it I
don't know how he is not just like if
you give me more than one thing to focus
on I'm stressed I'm anxious but the fact
that you have a whole studio and all
this TV and video games and Superman and
all that and it how are you not how do
you what do you do to make yourself not
stressed
well I meditate and I pray and I and I
do things you know and and I'm not going
to pretend like I'm not stressed but I
think in general
I'm okay I'm pretty fluid you know and I
think that I I have a great Acceptance
in you know
you know accepting what I cannot change
and Having the courage to change the
things that I can change and so I think
that being able to be you know sober
first of all is many years many years
sober
um being able to uh meditate being able
to uh you know realize that I can only
do what I can do when you have a job as
big as what my job is now like I could
be working 24 hours a day easily but I
kill yourself and kill myself and I can
only do what I can do and I know that I
need to take care of myself also frankly
I love working I'm not a guy who doesn't
like working somebody wrote me on
Twitter the other day they said you know
how do you balance you know pla you know
oh oh I know what it was I was saying
something I was reading as a comic book
I was reading Alan Moore's wild cats
comic and they said to me
um are you reading this for pleasure or
are you reading this for professional
reasons and I said and I didn't say
anything I don't think I just remember
seeing the thing and thinking about that
I'm like what why was I reading it and I
and I thought I do everything I do for
both of those things you know I mean if
you like something you want to make it
well I I'm inspired by things that I
read and I look for inspiration I look
for new ways of handling superheroes and
science fiction that are in comic books
um you know I look for characters that
we can use in the DCU in different ways
that maybe I don't know so much about
um but I'm also reading for pleasure
because I like reading comic books and
that's you know I'm gonna read that
right um some things are much more for
you know I read some comic book runs
that I'm not a great fan of that are you
know more specific to what our story
might be in the DCU that is a little bit
more professional and then I read other
things like you know Alan Moore which I
am reading in a lot of ways for for
pleasure as much as I am for
professional yeah but yeah everything's
a mix I like working you know I like
everything inspires everything else you
know do you think that there are two
obviously I'm asking a studio ahead so
this I you know I have a feeling what
the answer is going to be but you know
am I the first Studio ahead that you've
interviewed here
yeah I know a couple I should invite
them but no I don't want to
why because no it's a different it's
different you're a studio head but you
make huge movies and you direct them and
produce them and write them it's like
yeah it's just more interesting yes I
say yes or no do you think
that
there are too many
superhero shows and movies and because I
remember when I did Smallville yes there
were none yeah I do think there's too
many so what do you do about that um but
I don't think it's it's not it's it's
much less a problem of too many and yes
we are going to
we're not going to overextend ourselves
at DC we're going to be very careful
with the product that we put out and
making sure everything is as good as it
can possibly be
um
but
I think that what's happened is people
have gotten really lazy with their
superhero stories and they have gotten
the place where oh it's a it's a
superhero let's make a movie about it
you know and they make oh let's make a
sequel because the first one did pretty
well
and they aren't thinking about why is
this story special what makes this story
stand apart from other stories
what is the story at the heart of it all
why is this character important what
makes this story different that it it
fills a need for people in theaters to
go see you know or on television and
that's a hard thing and I think that
it's just that that's kind of gotten you
know people have gotten a little lazy
and there's a lot of you know Biff pow
bam stuff happening in in movies and
like I'm watching third acts of
superhero films where I really just
don't and I don't feel like there's a
Rhyme or Reason to what's happening I
don't care I don't care about the
characters right you know and it's like
and and they've gotten too generic like
there's this sort of
um
you know middle of the road
uh you know type of
you know genre tone that so many
superhero movies have as opposed to
having you know you know very different
genres I mean I like very serious
superhero movies I like very comedic
superhero movies I like ones that are
really just you know you know a murder
mystery but it's you know with
superheroes you know I like to see these
different types of stories as opposed to
seeing the same story told over and over
again I don't know how many times I you
know I don't want to go off anything no
you're not right well it's honest and I
think people really need to hear that
because it's it's sincere in a sense
that you're also a fan and you want to
make movies that have impact that have
them that people want to see and not
recycle things so you want to sort of
condense it to a let's make something
that we really not that people don't
work hard on everything they do
everything everybody works hard but the
stories have to be more compelling yeah
and I I think that also like and then
people say superhero fatigue but I think
that you know you see now that it's not
a real thing people have are fatigued
with repetition and I I don't think it's
really just superhero movies I think
you're seeing it happening now it's
spectacle films in general you know I
think it's more than that I think when's
the last great comedy can you remember
remember the last great comedy yeah but
there are so few of them made that you
don't have you know but but but there's
a lot of spectacle films made and they
just have gotten really generic and
they've gotten boring and they aren't
about characters and there's no emotion
to them and there's there should be
emotion and Things No Matter What like
that should always be there some type of
emotion I'm not saying it can't be
really light I'm not saying it can't be
really heavy I'm saying there should be
some sort of you're right and that goes
with horror and comedy everything that's
right it's just all this you gotta care
like in a horror movie if you like that
main character then you're much more
scared when they're about if you care
about them exactly if you take the time
to make the stakes matter and it doesn't
even matter big star ours think about it
if you put out a movie let's say James
Gunn put out a movie with DC for DC or
you made another Marvel's a suicide
what's this guy was DC but if you put it
out there and it was a bunch of no names
if the trailer's great people are going
to see it they don't care if so-and-so's
in my opinion especially horror movies
maybe not as much in the big Marvel DC
Universe maybe you need some stars but
like for them well I'm telling you you
know I know it's much more important to
me that the actor fits the role and look
I mean look at Guardians I mean Zoe was
somewhat of an established name when we
started out but she you know she was the
biggest star we had Chris wasn't and he
was the Chris wasn't a star exactly he
was not a star you know and and Dave
Batista was not an even known but don't
you think that's why it kind of worked
that's why it worked I don't think it's
because of that that it worked I think
that if we had a big star who came in
and killed a Star-Lord it would have
done well but I think that it's about
the performances first and foremost and
that when you have you know characters
like uh you know and those were unknown
characters by the way the characters
were not celebrities nobody I mean a
couple hundred thousand people read
Guardians Comics before the movie came
out yeah and they also changed changed a
lot over the years so there was no real
fan base just you know I didn't know
what the hell it was yeah I didn't know
what Guardians of the Galaxy was I
hadn't read the comics I wasn't I was a
horror movie fangori I know you read
fangoria so I wasn't so it was like it
was all it was definitely a like a not a
it was a risk yeah it was a risk because
people it wasn't something I mean like
Superman that they know okay we know
this we're it's you know Chris Pratt
gave a speech at the end of you know as
we were wrapping up um the third movie
and he gave this beautiful speech and he
was crying I didn't cry at all he was
crying profusely this is what he does
with Pratt this is their joke so he was
very much crying like a baby and it was
it was a little embarrassing and how
much went on and cried like I gotta say
understand that that's not what the
story is about but it was sort of
embarrassing how much he yeah he was a
big baby big baby and people a lot of
people were snickering I wasn't you know
a lot of people were laughing his wife
was embarrassed is well if we ever
showed the tape like in the behind the
scenes she's gonna yeah it's cringy
um no no he gave this beautiful speech
and in the speech what he get he was
reading off he went back and he looked
up all of the the articles that were
written about the Guardians before the
movie came out and he's quoting you know
this is going to be Marvel's first bomb
this is and it was just all this stuff
about nobody caring about these
characters you know wow and it was you
cried what you cried I I cried I got I
got I got I got teary I got teary I got
a male very masculine tear but I will
admit I cried a lot it's Zoe's speech it
was really yeah okay I think yeah
I don't know if you're [__] with
Pratt again on that I'm not I think he
probably gets jealous when I say that
but it's true I cried I cried a lot in
Her speech I wish people knew about they
were there on your wedding day when
Pratt read the um so James wrote
something for Pratt to read
and I'm not kidding I could not stop
laughing
everyone was just and it was like I have
everything I am to James Gunn without me
I'd still be the heavy set it was it
just went and it was like his wife's
much prettier than my wife I and it was
just and it went on yeah I wrote a
speech for Chris and he's he's read it
at the wedding and I've never shared
this but it's like I'd rather speak yeah
and he wrote this and he comes up and
goes
um you know my name is Chris Pratt and
uh and then he goes on bio everything I
have yeah he talks about how foxy my
wife is and how of course he's reading
with James Rose he's like you know I'm
married Catherine she's pretty good you
know I mean he he would break and he's
like I'm sorry Catherine I didn't uh you
know and uh and he he goes on and he
talked about how much better the
Guardians movies are than the Jurassic
Park movie or the Jurassic World movies
yes
the way he delivered it and uh and
people afterwards were like you know
because his acting was so good people
were like did you really not read that
till you went up there well half the
people were like Chris did you really
write I saw that at first yeah you
actually write this and it's like no no
I wrote it but he and then the other
half were like did you really not read
it before you went up there and because
he goes uh because he acted like he
hadn't read the speech before he started
it was so good but he had we had
actually come up we were flying back
from San Diego Comic-Con and we were
talking about what uh he was gonna read
at my wedding and then we came up with
that concept together so do you know
what the best part the best speech
though and I'm always saying this
because you talk about flawed characters
yeah and I think you write about flawed
characters knowing you because you are a
plot character and you kind of relate to
those characters who you know are
you know they're kind of that group of
guys that are Misfits it's like the the
land of Misfit Toys I think you called
us once they're all your friends you
know and it's like uh what was it
um Charlie in the Box I'm not you know
whatever that's you that's me I'm
William am I Charlie in the Box yeah
thank you your voice is that irritating
uh but you you said you had the speech
and um it was really personal and there
wasn't there was everybody there was
just holy [__] and it was the most
sincere most I mean I've seen you honest
but like this
you said something because I could
relate to that's why I think I was
crying I cried for sure I know Stevie
cried pretty much everybody cried but
you said
I knew I know intellectually I'm not I'm
not quoting you exactly you wrote it
much better than I'm gonna but you said
that my friends love me that my mom
loves me yeah
I know that because I'm smart enough to
understand that of course they love me
yeah but I don't
I've never been able to feel it yeah
that's that's true yeah and that crushed
a lot of people because I think
that is where a lot of people can kind
of kind of relate I I always feel like I
know I had these friends who love me
yeah for some reason I I don't think I'm
worthy of that yeah or I'm like and so
and then you met Jen and she taught you
how to love yourself in a way and there
was I don't know how you said it but
maybe you won all right yeah so and I've
shared this publicly before oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah I have
um the thing is is that I lived you know
I love creating and I love telling
stories but like a lot of people in the
entertainment industry I think that I
had an underlying desire to be loved you
know that my quest for fame and money
and notoriety and status was a quest to
have people love me so that I feel okay
about myself right yep um that's what
the a huge part of my quest was now
there was a healthy part of it which is
the part that like to create that like
to tell stories you know the part that
my you know my brothers and I plan with
you know Fisher Price characters you
know in the basement like you're still
telling stories in that way you're still
playing shooting eight millimeters I
mean all of that stuff but I really
wanted to be rich and famous like a lot
of people did I'm glad you admit that
because I don't know how many times I
said come on people will say oh I never
want to be famous I want to I think
that's a lot of [__] I think people
do want fame yeah yeah until you get it
yeah yes you're not happy before you get
it you're in trouble yeah yeah so uh I
think that you know
um and when I got fired which people
know happened
um uh you know I was temporarily fired
by by Disney and let go for a beat there
it was like holy [__] I've been working
my entire life
to be loved by all of these people by
the world so that I can feel okay about
myself in everything I've worked for is
gone like at that point I thought that I
was gonna have to sell my house you know
move away that my career was completely
over
and for a moment a brief moment
it was
uh really more than a brief point it was
devastating
for you know but really devastating for
about an hour
and then I started to try to take care
of myself do the best I can but the
thing that was so amazing to me was in
that moment of of lowness when
I couldn't help anyone you know because
I'd had a fair amount of power for a
while right
and I couldn't help anyone is when
people came to me and showed me the
greatest love people like you
especially my future wife Jen uh my
family my mom and dad
you know Chris Pratt Dave Batista Palm
clementia all the Guardians you know Zoe
coming over and cooking me dinner
um Sylvester Stallone
the amount of people people you know
that showed me this love in a moment
when I was completely weak my you know
my agents Simon Hatt my producer
um all of these people just it was
stunning to me and for the first time in
my I felt like for the first time in my
life I felt loved
and so that thing that I had been
searching for my entire life to feel
loved from something outside of me to
make myself feel okay
I could not experience it until I let go
of my desperation to receive it
and that was when I felt
um truly okay and I I woke up that
morning thinking this is the worst day
of my entire life I laid in bed that
whole night going I hate being [__]
famous I hate being [__] famous I
hate it I hate it I hate it and I woke
up that morning it was the worst day of
my entire life and I went to bed that
night and I was lying next to Jen and I
looked over at her and I realized how
much I loved her I realized that I
wanted to marry her
and uh and I said this is the best day
of my life I'm actually you know myself
and uh it only took me another uh five
years to ask her to marry me
but it was but it was yeah but really
that was that was for me that was the
beginning of everything that was the
beginning of the second life that was
that was me really being able to then
focus and say okay let go of the need to
be loved let go of the need to be rich
like what I need to just focus on is why
do I love making movies and it's for the
story it's I love the characters it's
the collaboration with the other
department heads the other filmmakers
the actors like that's why I love making
movies and telling stories I love the
audience reacting to my movies I love
the fact right now that you know
um you know people all over the world
every day are saying you know such sweet
things it really is about the creative
process for me and if I can focus on
that
um then that's what makes me happy you
know it's awesome man that's awesome
it's amazing how um you've told it but
you think something is going to make you
happy you think the money the fame this
and all of a sudden you get thrown on
your ass and you're just like you're
numb I know that numb feeling that numb
feeling of just like almost like
embarrassed shame of nothing and you're
like who really is gonna be there
because you don't expect that moment to
happen at this point in your life and
then boom and they're like we love you
yeah we don't care well that's and the
weird thing was too Michael that like
the the thing was was I think oh people
like me because I'm smart and I make
good movies and I direct them well it's
not for the real you
you know that is part of me I know
that's all part of me but the thing that
really saved me was that I had been
incredibly kind to people over the years
you know and so by being kind to people
by being kind to my crew people by
making them feel like people by giving
them Respect by forming genuine bonds
with human beings that wasn't just about
career or getting something out of them
or whatever that was the the thing that
I felt that I had put into my life that
had worked so well was just a gentle
kindness to everyone
um and I'm not saying I'm not a saint
right I'm not kind all the time it's not
like there haven't been times when I've
been unkind but in general I've been
really kind to people throughout my
entire career and it makes all the
difference it does and a lot of people
aren't you know I was just talking about
this about you know especially with
Studio heads and you know I'm ultimately
whether you're in a re in the real world
and you work for a corporation or you
work for Disney or whoever you work with
a lot of times
um when you renegotiate you really feel
unloved and like on not disrespected and
you know and I don't know how many times
where it's just like
but when you negotiate often times the
first time it's the worst yeah but it
could be so much not even the money if
creators or header Studios could just
give a call every once in a while to
just say or or talk to someone yeah not
even get heads of Studios I'm talking
about from whoever from a director to
just saying hey I really want to say I
appreciate your work and thanks for all
your hard work that's it something
instead of just coming into to there's
just like if it's more of a connection
these things don't sort of happen as big
and I just think that that's part of you
know I think greed is more prominent
than ever Maybe not maybe it's always
been there and greed has been there but
you know I always feel like if I have if
I'm doing something and it's making a
little money I'm gonna give this guy
who's working with me or helping me a
little bit of something yeah I'm gonna
try and I'm gonna try it because I want
to I want them to know that I really
love them and I I appreciate them it's
got to be hard to be a studio head and
do that because you you know how hard
you know how can you do that yeah well I
think it's you know I listen I'm my
job's the same I'm still directing right
I'm just directing bigger projects and
different things and so I think that
it's through appreciation you know and
you know uh it's something I was modeled
quite well for me by Kevin feige and Lou
de Esposito who are the heads of Marvel
and who always let me know that they
appreciated my work you know I always
knew that they appreciated it like I
always came in under budget and I knew
they appreciated that I always knew that
they liked the movies themselves that I
was creating so I think that you need to
let people know that I think that my my
cast knows how much I appreciate what
they do and the crew the crew hugely
like you know a lot of directors you
just never hear the crew come out of
their mouths when they're doing
interviews yeah but you know I talk
about Beth Mickel who's my production
designer all the time I talk about
Giuliana mikovsky who does my costume
designs awesome those by the way
you know I hired a new editor yesterday
he came in and I said you got to get
used to we do a different thing you know
we we I really
the Departments all work together like I
have a crew of people around me now have
been around me for a long time and
Juliana and Beth are on all my phone
calls because the three of us together
along with Steph are VFX supervisor and
Henry uh the DP they're gonna get the
vision we are all the Aesthetics of
Superman right so we all have to work
together to create this one unified
aesthetic the same thing that we all did
on suicide squad the same thing we all
did on Guardians three we have to work
together to create one unified aesthetic
and so it's not really a there's not a
sharp division between photograph and
set or because costume and hair right
right and set and so there those people
are a part of all these choices you know
and we interact with makeup with hair
with Legacy or you know prosthetic
effects Department all of those things
have to work together because one thing
I noticed early on when I started
directing bigger movies was I would
watch other big movies and I want to
name them but occasionally I'd see
another big movie where it's like well
you can tell that the costume designer
wasn't on the same page with the set
designer wasn't on the same page with
the hair designer and those they were
they're all individually great pieces of
work but together they don't fit they
don't have to be a palette they don't
look like they're it's well it's a
similar palette but it's also just
there's a look there's an aesthetic that
you want to you know put against
everything yeah you know and so and
especially with my movies with you know
with with how we're doing Superman we're
creating a an aesthetic that hasn't ex
you know existed before so it's what is
that now I have to say it but I mean
it's about creating something different
and so you really need to make sure that
everybody
you know I started talking about uh
about how those people aren't mentioned
and I just went on to other stuff but
anyway but most people aren't properly
right and you don't
and like everybody's actors actors
actors actors and the actors are
incredibly important they create a lot
but man you know if you talk about an
actor versus what Beth Mickel did who
created all the sets like really the
biggest voice is beths yeah she's you
know in terms of what Guardians 3 is
Beth is as important as as anybody yeah
um
with Superman I know you can't talk too
much about it I mean you mentioned in a
couple of tweets is it true that
there'll be a crypto dog crypto the dog
is that what it's called
there is a dog named crypto in the
comics yeah so was that just a tweet you
can't mention or you're smiling yeah I
didn't say that in a tweet oh you didn't
no oh somebody else was doing that
yeah somebody somebody mentioned
corrupted maybe it was a joke
so who knows yeah Chris Pratt and I were
talking about crypto in a uh interview
and I said no that he could play crypto
oh okay and then Chris goes oh now we're
saying that crypto's in the movie that's
a scoop ah gotcha um
do you feel like out of all the big
movies you've done and you've done big
[__] movies
is and be honest you will be yeah do you
feel the most precious uh pressure with
Superman I did up until I finished the
script
now it's fun
you love the script I love the script
and people love the script and so like I
feel great about the script right I felt
a shitload of pressure at the beginning
like what am I doing
why am I doing this do you go through
those phases why am I doing this
definitely but I think that it was you
know people know I was offered Superman
years ago
I said no because I I didn't know quite
how to tackle it
and
um I think that you know
but because of that I kept thinking
about it and thinking about it and
thinking about how could I create a
Superman that's true to the character of
Superman that absolutely loves the
character Superman
and yet is a take on Superman that's
different enough that it's worth you
know making a big budget movie about it
um that it's worth people seeing it that
it won't be boring you know all of those
things so uh so yeah so now I I yeah so
now I feel good about it so now it's fun
now we're just finding and and then I
felt a lot of pressure frankly
finding you know casting the roles sure
and you know saying God is there Eve I
know how hard it was so hard to find
Star-Lord I can't tell you I looked at
hundreds oh yeah I met with you you did
yeah and I know yours was the worst it
was yeah oh I'm aware of it
no I mean I saw so many people for Star
Wars I couldn't find the right person
until Chris
um and so I was worried about that but
now that we've kind of done a lot of
auditions when we're narrowing it down
we're not done yet by the way there's a
lot of stories out there about who we're
auditioning and all these screen tests
you know I'm just saying it's not all
true that's for sure like there's things
in there that are completely false but I
I can't go out there and say oh this
isn't true and this isn't true without
saying you know can I ask you this going
through everything and by the way it's
not the audience is you know right now
at this point I don't think it's the
business of anyone who's screen testing
for a role that is a very private thing
so someone does that shut your mouth
someone's putting well listen
journalists have to do what they have to
do that's their job how would a
journalist fight they're trying to get
hits
they find out some things from agencies
but here's the problem is that they find
out some things from agencies that might
be true they find out other things from
agencies which are agencies pushing
their clients and trying to Pump It Up
like look don't you see it because
there's been some things out there I'm
like why I think this person I think my
clan is testing yeah so it's like it's
like there's a lot of nonsense that
comes out of it and that's that's
difficult because there's people out
there that are supposedly testing that
aren't and that must be difficult for
them as people uh and there's other
people that might be testing that might
be testing yeah and that are out there
that might be testing and I think it's
not it it's a private thing between me
and them or someone that puts themselves
on tape and then they say oh I tested
well you put yourself on tape that well
that happens too that happens well the
thing that you know that happens also is
people say hey they offered me this
movie like directors do that I had that
with somebody who's on my podcast I know
yeah they offered me the Rolex Lutheran
no they didn't they didn't offer anybody
they're all excellent then I called the
Creator and go hey dude uh this gives no
yeah that's yeah no we had somebody say
that we had these directors say it about
a DC project they offered us this
project I'm like no no they met with one
of our Executives about potential
projects to pitch on right that isn't
the same as yeah probably you just have
to let it go and go I'm not [__] even
entertaining this yeah you know what I
mean so but whatever the case there's a
lot of untruths out there sure um let me
ask you this or just promise that or
will the Lex Luthor character they'll be
a Lex Luthor right
Finn isn't that already known yeah they
think everybody thinks there's a Lex
Luthor out there but I've never said
there was Alexa there in there all right
so if there were Alexa if there were
Alex Luther okay if there were Alex
Luther in this movie and there's a lot
of other villains so it may not be like
and you are the best Lex let's admit it
we know you're the best Lex come on
you're being funny I'm not being funny
you're definitely the best Lex really
definitely
but not right for your movie not right
for Mike I didn't say there was even
Alexa I know but if there were elects
Luther
promise me this uh-huh
you'll he'll be
he'll have gravitas or he'll have uh
he'll have a he'll he'll be Lex Luthor
he won't be a playing playing Lex Luthor
but he's more acting like this character
or this or goofy or crazy he's gonna be
something that's grounded and real I
know you I'm sure that's everything yeah
yeah everything's right because I'm not
saying anybody's done that I'm just
saying that that you know maybe if
somebody's done that maybe maybe that's
happened but
yeah anyway we'll continue on uh this is
uh this is one of my last questions
you've worked on Marvel and DC films
howdy the two universes differ in terms
of tone style and approach to
storytelling and what are some of the
challenges and opportunities that come
with working in each
um I don't think that there's any you
know I don't think you can
because relatively
um the MCU and now the DCU in film which
really doesn't start I mean the first
DCU character for sure is Blue Beetle in
the First full DC move DCU movie is
Superman
um
it you know the now that that's
happening it's it's relatively new the
same thing with with Marvel I mean even
MCU is relatively new so I don't know if
there's any innate things about tone
because I think that what both MCU and
DCU need to do is to have a wider range
of tones than they presently do
um
I think they work to do that but I think
they can do a better job of it yep
um
the biggest but but if you look at the
MCU there are very few superheroes
the you know there are very few
traditional superheroes there was never
a guy with a secret identity until
Spider-Man and the MCU
their cap was turned into a soldier even
though he wears a mask and that's all
there was in DC you know Iron Man
doubted himself at the end of the first
Iron Man because they don't want to deal
with the secret identity stuff so there
is a bit more of a fantasy element to
DCU
um because there are these Larger than
Life superheroes and you can't take that
you're not going to make I mean people
are going to do whatever they're going
to do in the future but for me you know
there's Superman and Clark Kent like
they're two different characters and you
have to find a whale to deal with them
um that's as grounded as possible within
this world of DC one of the things I
love about DC and excites me about DC is
that in a way it is it's another
alternate history you know it is Gotham
City and metropolis and Star City and
bloodhaven and and you know all these
different places in this this other
reality and it makes it a little bit
like Westeros in some ways
um I love that about it I love that we
get to create True World building in DC
it isn't just we're throwing some
superheroes on Earth yeah you know
I like that so I think that right now
that's one of the key differences what's
your favorite Marvel movie besides
Guardians
um MCU are Marvel both
my favorite MCU movie is Iron Man the
original yes love it I think it's
incredibly great movie
um
but my favorite Marvel movie is probably
Deadpool which really well actually no
my favorite Marvel movies into the
spider-verse
people love that movie yeah everybody
loves that movie it's great I haven't
seen it yeah
I know I'm gonna see it oh dude it's the
best superhero movie ever made really I
think so you love it that much I do love
it DC favorite movie of all time DC
movie uh super first Superman I mean
it's uh behind you
signed by Gene Hackman oh that's pretty
cool you're better than you did a better
job he I love Gina but he played you
know he played I loved it anyway
I foreign
I couldn't lay down because I would get
makeup on there that was a whining the
audience I should have cried with Pratt
on that you you complained a lot about
your bowl all right well is Peacemaker
really coming back or is there just no
time for it no peacemakers coming back
right after Superman that's my next
thing so then you'll just walk straight
into Superman yeah I mean go straight
from Superman to piece Suicide Squad too
the wallers first and wallers allowed
the same people from peacemakers so I
mean this is all yeah but yeah
Suicide Squad 2. is there no you don't
have any I plans for doing that
all right this is last this is the [__]
talking these are my top tier patrons
it's rapid fire all right [__] talking
with James Gunn uh patreon.com inside
you thank you for listening you guys
make the show possible uh James Gunn
what is your all-time favorite TV theme
song
now that you can name mine probably
my favorite I mean I'm sure there's one
that I I like more but I think of the
Taxi theme song
yeah because at your heart yeah yeah
because it gives you that feeling you
know what was it done oh so welcome
Welcome Back Cotter what about welcome
back oh well the names of all changes
hang on wait what was it uh
dude we'll edit this don't worry
dude that is I think that's mine I'm not
I'm I swear to God I'm not saying it
this is my
favorite
it's a different version yeah that's a
weird yeah find the right but come on
that's a
I mean love it there's something about
that driving around the bridge yeah and
you're just like I think about being
like it's just so peaceful also Mash
yeah Mash is good Hill Street Blues like
you know there's certain ones that that
I remember from childhood that make me
feel like you know certainly yeah
calmness yeah I love that
um if Nathan Jay at the Guardians of the
Galaxy Fought The Suicide Squad who
would win
uh
uh I think Suicide Squad guys are more
violent they're they're more willing but
I I just don't I think that listen I
always thought that uh the Guardians
would beat the [__] out of the Avengers
easily like it's just they're outer
space they have technology that is you
know um
pretty Advanced so be hard to beat them
Dave P anymore a sleeper 80s hair metal
bands you plan to use for the theme
songs and upcoming projects oh well I
mean Peacemaker season two I've already
got a I love that music yeah that's
that's a great you know that's my I like
that [__] and you like there's a lot of
cool modern bands yes you know Wigwam
um uh Cruel Intentions it just goes with
the show it's just it's it's it's it's
like it's like you have your actors the
music it all comes to you know what I
mean man I got a new soundtrack for
Creature Commandos which is that's
actually the first D full DCU project so
that's the animated show we're doing you
know and that comes out in
um
you know a year or so but it's uh we're
recording it all now you know I do
voiceovers I've been doing voiceovers
for my entire life anyway Michelle K
what's something surprising you learned
about yourself in the last year Well we
think we talked about that well that was
that was more than a year ago
in the past year
I'll think about it in the past year you
got married you took over DC you uh you
bought a house uh and again I won't say
it yeah Colorado
yeah
um you've been transitioned back and
forth to LA and uh Atlanta yes so uh
how you feeling uh
I'm just trying to think of something
I've learned about myself in the past
year
do you miss seeing your friends so as
frequently as we always used to hang
obviously you can't because yeah I miss
seeing my friends uh
as often as I did yeah
could answer
thanks dude uh Nick Nico P you do such
an amazing job of leaving humor and
emotion into your films who helped
influence that for you or was it just
like something you just
um I Look to a lot of different you know
filmmakers and storytellers that I like
but you know
I go back to Preston Sturgis who was you
know great uh comedy filmmaker uh you
know from the uh you know the 40s mostly
and um
50s and who created just these really
you know wonderful beautiful emotional
and hilarious stories like Sullivan's
travels yeah you know so uh you know but
yeah I think that there's that you know
there's Superman there's there's you
know Star Wars films had that
Raj tell me what you miss most about
your life prior to finding success in
the film industry
one of the weird things for me is My
Success has been you know there's jumps
but
I it's been incredibly gradual yeah
really gradual yeah so you know I
started working professionally in my 20s
making movies for trauma and to me that
was as exciting as anything because all
of a sudden I'm making a living making
movies I remember going on the subway
every day to the set of Romeo and Juliet
and going oh my God I can't believe
they're spending 350
000 making this movie that seemed to be
an astronomical sum
so
everything's been pretty gradual you
know and and and and I've been in the
film industry for you know my adult life
for the most part
uh and was working professionally as a
musician before that yeah so it has
happened like you know for instance I
always talk about it but like on on
Smallville Tom Welling had overnight
success it really just that's right I I
never had that you never had that I was
like doing uh independent or a short or
whatever I had elephants sure you know I
mean I remember that you know the
morning that uh Scooby-Doo opened up
Lorenzo de bonaventura called me at 5 30
on Saturday morning and said the movie
made 18 million dollars yesterday that
was an enormous sum and I knew at that
moment that my career as a screenwriter
was sort of set so it was huge you know
same thing with guardians when the first
Guardians opened up and you know I'm
getting a call on Friday night saying
that you know the movie was supposed to
make 60 and the movie and or no I think
the movie was supposed to make like 45
or something I can't remember
97 I think opening weekend so it was
like instantly I knew [__] I'm a made
man as a director like that was huge
so uh you know I have had those huge
those huge moments yeah you know what's
great about uh
being friends with someone who has you
know a lot of money in power
um when you took me to that restaurant
uh the uh Michelin
what was it I don't know what you're
talking about yeah for the bachelor
party oh yeah yeah we went to to uh yeah
I never would have ever I never I really
have good meals as it is the 13 course
and I just was like Rooker and I were
looking at each other while right and
going
the hell man
it's great what is this I don't know
[__] it I'm eating it yeah we didn't
care what it was we just kept eating it
Rooker and I have eaten in a lot of nice
restaurants well that one was holy [__]
for me I'm talking forever and I went to
Paris together
sorry yeah you're telling me yeah we
went on a romantic trip to Paris and uh
and just went every night we went to
another uh you know three Michelin star
restaurant we had incredibly great meals
the funniest part was the first night we
went to like a place that was really
delicious but not too expensive and I
paid
and the next night we went to the next
place and Brook was like I'll take this
one and it was I had a 3 000. did he
mention it
and he didn't he didn't say like oh man
maybe you want to chip in this one he's
like he's like that's what I got paid
for Guardians one last question Jessica
B when was the last time you said no and
felt good about it felt knowing said no
that's a really interesting question I
mean
um
I mean I think that the worst thing
about being a studio
person is I didn't know the amount of of
I never really considered the amount of
people we were going to need to say no
to no we're not picking up your show or
no we're not going to you know whatever
I like it is the freaking worst and it's
not a big part of my job actually but
it's the it's it's the worst yeah
um you know because it's always been
much more about me I've always is a
director I've always had to hire people
and
um you know I feel like I've said yes to
a lot of people I guess I have to say no
because people audition and they don't
get the gig yeah but and I guess I just
always focus more on the yeses than on
the nose right and I feel the nose more
uh in my gut now
um yeah that makes sense so but I I say
no every day and I feel good about it
you know surprised you didn't say no to
this podcast James yeah I've said no
lots of times you did you did yeah I'm
grateful that you came over it's the
only podcast I'm doing is that true yes
thank you I'm doing it because we're
friends did you enjoy this no okay yeah
last question uh I said that four times
um no we're really almost done we
started a little late but you got to get
out of here lastly about your your dad I
loved Jimmy senior he was the best uh he
just had such a presence every one of
your friends I mean I would text him
yeah I would I loved him I know he
passed and I know that the families
going out to Ireland to scatter his
ashes yeah when are you doing that I'm
doing that on Monday are you really yeah
it's happening that soon yeah are you
are you expecting a pretty emotional
Journey with the family
I don't know listen
my dad want me to scatter his ashes so
I'm going to Ireland to scatter his
ashes we've had the funeral I cry all
the time about my dad it's not like I
don't cry about my death of course I cry
about my dad once a week at least you
know yeah cry about my dog cried about
my dog this morning I was telling my the
person cutting my hair about my dog
Wesley and how he passed away the best
um so uh just don't do it like Big
Lebowski
don't do what I remember the ashes yeah
yeah
yeah yeah so no no so we're going to you
know the county you know you know our
home how many people how many family
members
all the kids so it's it's you know six
kids and then a lot of the significant
others are going so you know we're all
married so there's I don't know maybe
four four of the significant others are
going nice maybe a couple that yeah some
of the nephews and nieces are going to I
think
awesome this has been awesome really I
loved having you I love it's like the
most I've well I came over your house a
while ago and we talked but this is like
one-on-one yeah and I don't want to take
as much as I could with me yeah yeah so
yeah I love it I mean I listen it's
always fun being here it's always very
natural yeah it is all right okay buddy
I love you thanks man bye
I love that interview and what's great
is we didn't you know you know a lot of
times you have to cut out a lot of stuff
you're talking to a studio head and
James you know he wasn't like that he's
like yeah it's great let's do it this
Bible says we're cool they're like we'd
like to hear it first
and uh you know we didn't change
anything uh it was it was easy uh fun uh
it just again felt like two guys two
buddies having a conversation it wasn't
hard for me at all the the what do you
think uh no I can tell you guys have a
history and
um it's uh It's gotta be weird to watch
like especially like just to be in your
20s in LA and then just to watch
everyone's careers go
and then watch some people like
Skyrocket and some people just plateau
and then some people go the opposite
direction it's got to be weird you
insinuating my career is going nowhere
you skyrocketed wow
James Gunn is just plateaued no he is
he's just you know what I was thinking
about this I knew a lot of people on the
way up or the way down or my you got
your career goes up and down of course
you can't you just can't keep going up
people have lulls people have but it's
the perseverance it's the you know an
adversity hits you like we talk in the
podcast about all the [__] that went
down and you find your real friends that
are there for you and still love you and
that's when you really find happiness
you know when you can say hey I I am I
made a mistake and I did and you still
have people there to support and love
you it's that that's that's a that's a
it's a good thing it's a good feeling
um I've had that in my life you know
where I just really for lack of a better
word hit a wall and went to a place to
um help myself and get my my head clear
and um
so it was it was uh it's good it's good
to see and I and I've been around I'm
not that old but I am old now older
I look a little younger than I am let's
be honest that's true that's good thank
you that's my it's it's lack of work
um but you know I remember seeing
Bradley Cooper at a bar and talking to
him and hanging out with him and he was
going through a dark time on um that
show that he was on back in the in the
2000s it wasn't uh Angel Dark Angel it
was um
it was the one with Jennifer Garner
Alias Alias and um and then look at his
career it just couldn't have gotten
bigger and then you know I remember
seeing Chris Pratt at a party and
hanging out with him and just a lovable
guy
that hasn't changed a bit and now
Blockbuster movie star
and it's nice to see good things happen
to good people
um
I've certainly hung out with people that
have skyrocketed that I'm like
could have happened to a better person
you know and then you see a lot of
actors that are way better than me and a
lot of other actors and they just can't
seem to
find their way or get that lucky break
and uh
but it's the work you got to put the
work in and it's not gonna just happen
it's not the old days where somebody
sees a good looking guy hey you I want
you to be in this lead role in my movie
it just doesn't happen and people wait
for that I think people still think
that's gonna happen you've got to go out
there man you've got to knock on every
door you've got to look like an [__]
you've got to fail and fail and build
some integrity and um boring myself here
we go
um
thank you James thank you thanks
everybody for listening Please Subscribe
write a review helps the show follow us
on our handles and uh here are the top
tier patrons patreon.com inside you
these folks do wonders for my my career
and and the podcast
um you guys support the podcast there's
a lot of perks I send boxes every couple
months and uh to the top tiers and I I
try to message people as much as I can
and I see my cons it's like a big family
so join here are the top tiers Nancy D
Leah k
little Lisa Yukiko Jill e Bryan H Nico P
Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D
Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Mike e l Don Supremo 99 more Santiago am
Chad W Liam P Maya P Maddie s
how about a drink of water Belinda and
Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T
Tom and Talia M at CD I like how Ryan
read a few Ryan never gets to read a few
I I pull it up on my uh my phone no but
I'm glad you're reading a few now I
think it's just because we we just
recorded a taco one and Tom just takes
it you guys just alternate yeah I was
feeling that flow Tom hogs out he's
awesome you notice that he says most of
the names
it's okay
Betsy D Angel amren and see Cory K Dev
Nixon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D Joey
M Eugene and Leanne I apologize again
Eugene and Leah I had to kick you out of
the um I didn't kick you out but the
baby was crying in the Smallville nights
and uh we you know the people we just
couldn't have a baby crying the whole
time so she was a good sport and uh if I
hooked her up with some extra pictures
at the table and signed them and you
know and I told him next time you guys
come to us uh uh Smallville nights it's
on me it's on me and Tom and uh also at
that phillycon Ryan by the way I forgot
to bring the cards we give these
keepsakes and it's the first time I just
I don't know I forgot and so that's why
we gave like 15 or more prizes at the
end instead of like four or five but
some people I think were disappointed
that they didn't get the Keepsake you
know that they were supposed to get
everyone and I just I didn't know what
to do
so if you're upset come see me at a
table at a con I'll make it up to you
um some way believe me I will I
apologize for that [__] happens so leave
me alone Corey Heather L Angela F Mel s
Carolyn R Christine s Eric H sh shaynar
Andrew M timel Oracle Amanda R Jen B
Kevin e Stephanie K Jarrell Jammin J
Leanne J Luna R Mike F Stone H Brian L
Aaron R Kendall L Meredith I Kara C
Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P Estevan G
Kaylee J Brian a Ashley F Marion Louise
L Romeo B Veronica Q Frank B gen t Nicki
l
I love you and thank you patreon.com
inside of you thanks for listening I
hope you really enjoyed this podcast and
um from the Hollywood Hills in
California I'm Michael Rosenbaum I'm
Ryan Taylor's all right I know how are
you doing uh people miss you Bill they
like you you have to come to a con with
me someday would you just gotta give me
a plane ticket yeah I'll pay for you to
come out you just hang out with me great
you can just experience it yeah
someplace that's close all right guys
take care and uh be good to yourself
I'll see you next week
[Music]